okay we are going to get started now so
thank you all for being here welcome
good evening and welcome to the national
design center for this
visions of the future discussion event
we do have a small and socially
distanced audience tonight as
is the new norm um it's much smaller
than our usual audience size and that's
the sign of the very difficult year that
we've all had
and talking about difficulties i think
always helps with resolving them so
that's what we're doing tonight will be
holding a design lens to the post
pandemic world
[Music]
meeting in person for an event does feel
like something of a novelty now doesn't
it
and having my mask off around other
people so thanks to all of you who are
here tonight
it's great really great to be able to
look out and see people in physical form
i'm narelle yabuka from the design
singapore council or dsg and it's my
pleasure to be here with you tonight
but as we do all live in two worlds
these days you might also be joining us
virtually for this session through a
post event video
which is appearing on the websites of
visions of the future
dsg and design anthology the visions of
the future website
was developed by design anthology who is
our online and programming partner for
the exhibition
the site offers a virtual experience of
the exhibition content
and you can find it at visions of the
future future.sg
for those of us here irl tonight i'd
like to remind you please to observe the
required safety measures please make
sure you have your mask on at all times
please keep a one metre distance between
individuals
and please avoid physical contact such
as handshaking during the event
we do have hand sanitizer at the front
there and also in the lift lobby and
you're welcome to use that
and thank you for adhering to these
guidelines and of course some things
don't change pandemic or not so please
make sure your devices are set to silent
mode
tonight's event titled design for a post
pandemic world
is the first of three panel discussions
that will investigate the work presented
in the visions of the future exhibition
which is currently
on show downstairs now this is
a sort of a closing ceremony of sorts
for the exhibition
which is actually ending tonight but of
course the digital exhibition will go on
so do head there
if you'd like to take another look at
the work this panel discussion and the
two upcoming ones are developed by
design anthology and our thanks go to
the editor-in-chief susie annetta and
her team
for their efforts tonight we'll focus on
the
exhibited work of four of the emerging
singapore designers featured in the show
they're all here tonight um we'll also
be prodding at the themes that arise
from the show
and i'm i'm very certain that they're
all going to resonate with us all
whether or not we are designers
i'm going to sit down and get comfy and
not used to wearing heels these days
okay so let me give you a little bit of
background to the exhibition
the visions of the future is the first
show that we've held in the national
design center atrium space
since the re-opening of the venue which
happened in august
the show was produced by dsg and curated
and designed by wendy choi and gustavo
maggio of forest and whale
the exhibition construction was by
superstructure and the visual identity
is by fifth column
the show features the work of a number
of singapore's next-gen of design talent
and thanks to its curatorial angle of
imagining
new rituals for living it's been a
really timely meditation
on what we should demand from the new
normal
the show was actually a long time in the
making and it began with an open call to
emerging singapore designers back in
2019
originally it was planned for a showing
in italy during milan design week
2020 which of course was cancelled and
as wendy described in her
curator's note accompanying the show the
designers have been developing
many of the ideas within the exhibition
since before the pandemic struck
but she rightly said the futures they
envision remain
pertinent if not urgent in light of the
harsh realities and inequalities that
ignited during this public health crisis
it does feel right that a show based on
visioning the future focuses on the
younger generation of designers because
after all they're the ones who have
the greatest hand in shaping their
future
to echo the words of dsg's executive
director mark we this exhibition is just
one of the ways that dsg develops the
next generation of design
talent and we hope to run a lot more
capability development initiatives in
the years to come
so why does it make sense to talk about
design for a post-pandemic world
well as we we're all waiting for the
rollout of vaccines in 2021 and there's
a feeling that
this could be a really pivotal moment
but it's one that i think is really
underscored by
you know uncertainty trepidation and
especially
given that emergence of the new strain
of the virus so
it's really easy to wonder are the
lifestyles that we knew in 2019
now permanently past tense will we have
them back at all
and you know we could feel feel
completely dislocated
and fearful but for those of us who've
got a vested interest in design
i think we owe it to ourselves and to
others to also side with
hope and progress despite the fear
and we have the unique position to use
design proactively to shape the new
normal sensitively and with intelligence
as well
so the designers featured in the visions
of the future show
that this is an opportunity to
scrutinize the values that we're
bringing to the world through design
we've got the chance now to reset our
position on the very purpose of design
and tonight we're lucky to have kevin
um you're right
it's the first time meeting everybody in
person gotta make sure i have
everybody's names right cheryl
and young schwein with us as speakers
and we'll see their work as well as
other pieces from the exhibition in our
accompanying
slideshow tonight
okay we're almost ready for the
questions but i'd just like to introduce
each of you first to
give everybody a sense of who you are so
cheryl
is number three over there cheryl tang
is an industrial designer and producer
and she's currently working in the
studio of
hans tun her key focal points are
materiality and tactility
and her works explore relationships
between materials people and objects
as you'll see in her visions of the
future project pneumatics touch
unruh second chair there po yunru is a
socially in
engaged product designer and also a
teaching assistant in industrial design
currently working at the design
incubation center at nus
she focuses on creating a positive
impact on society
by improving the lives of others
illustrated beautifully in her work
rewind
a device for seniors
in the fourth chair over there is a
multi-disciplinary designer currently
working in the furniture sector
she graduated from the design academy
eindhoven
and she seeks to revive the joy of
making what we use
her exhibited project mass production of
happiness
a soap making system is part of a
collection that she hopes to evolve
further as she reimagines our ecosystem
of industrial design
and beside me kevin chum is an
industrial designer by training but he's
currently working in ui
ux and strategy design at deloitte
digital
he graduated from the royal college of
art and imperial college in london
his work on inclusive design has won
various international
awards congratulations and he has
exhibited three projects in visions of
the future
echo a product to prompt rapid building
evacuation
odor ring a piece of jewelry that
discourages the wearer from touching
their face
and soap tattoos which he designed with
nacho villanova
a motivational soap for kids so please
join me in welcoming them all with a
round of applause
okay my first icebreaker question for
all of you
is what's a design or a design related
initiative that you've seen during the
pandemic and it could be by anyone in
the world
that really resonated with you and what
does it say to you about design's
potential
would you like to go first kevin yeah
so i guess one of the more memorable
projects personally
that resonated strongly with me there is
a project
by this company called kendo it's a tech
company that's
based in israel in particular
israeli city and basically they use
or rather they focus on waste management
their strengths lie
in data visualization and so what was
unique and what was their contribution
to the covalent situation was that they
found that you can actually
detect a virus in the waste water or
rather the switch
right and they are able to actually
detect them much faster
and you can visualize that information
and pass that information to
sort of accelerate different government
initiatives to cut the spread of
quotation
so i think that is something that was
to me i felt it's quite brilliant
initiative simply because
they started with a very unconventional
perspective
so we're not looking at swapping people
and getting samples from laser passages
but rather it's more about
understanding where else are you able to
detect and
present the information in a way that is
very helpful in the public
so i guess in a way this is where design
can also be
yeah and i guess visualizing that
information as well
you're enroute okay so
so what she did was like a platform to
allow people to kind of
send their recordings off like their
live experiences
during the period i think what i really
liked about
what she did was how um it allowed
people to easily like connect
to share to speak and allow us to listen
and to kind of care for others during
this period of time and to also pay
attention to what
kind of evolve and change and this is
what i'm actually trying to do
for my project now if you receive the
exhibition
i have a object of memory where i kind
of collectively
want people to contribute in providing
content that will help
elderly from different cultural
backgrounds yeah so i feel designed for
me it's quite important
that we kind of connect people together
yeah so sort of building on the empathy
yeah
okay for me
it's not a project that came out of
pandemic per se but uh
is this project by argentina the
student designer i mean it was a student
project called uh
aldana garcia is the sky window but
actually she did that when she was
in rca i really liked that project i
think that
project um to me related quite strongly
with cove because it was about
we spent a lot of time at home right now
right and uh
we want to get like during especially
during circuit breaker we wanted to get
out in the sky the sky
more sky window is actually um a
hybrid between a balcony and a window
where you can lay back and look at and
daze at the sky
almost like you're out out there and i
think that's
it's quite amazing to me how like
something that was
design she designed it in 2018 or 2019
if i'm not wrong
uh something that was designed prior
could be something so relevant
uh in the current climate yeah
for me it's not so much of a project but
as an initiative
that um started just during the covet
where every uh it was founded it's
called design emergency then
founded by alice roston and
paolo antonilli if i pronounce her name
correctly
and actually they just brought in like
it's just a platform where they talk to
a lot of
designers from all over the world to
discuss about the pandemic
and i thought that it's really nice
initiative because like for
for example we are all supposed to go to
milan where you are physically in
at an exhibition but then now everything
has gone online
and it's so much more accessible for not
just for designers but for everyone
and like they actually conduct like live
interviews um
very frequently with like different
designers to just discuss about the
pandemic
and i thought that was like the kind of
information that was very accessible
and like about the research and all
these things behind that actually
not so much red is a need but it's i
think it's a good initiative that
inspires me as some like a researcher
and a designer
yeah i've been following that ig account
as well myself
okay so there's quite a bit of emphasis
on human connection
in what what you've said so what has the
past year been like for all of you on a
personal level
and as a designer how has your life and
your design
discipline been affected by covert 19
maybe i'll start with you
cheryl just trying to mix it up
for me i thought it was a rather
refreshing year because it never
occurred to me like how
much more connected and dependent to the
community we actually are
because myself i am a i'm a maker
designer i make most of my pieces myself
i mean i have a few pieces that are
fabricated but
um i realized that even even so even
though i make most of the pieces myself
i relied a lot on my community like the
the materials that i purchased um like
getting
connecting with fabricators and yeah i
realized that actually
no matter how independent you are you
are part of the community
yeah so that's that
unruly i think for me because i'm
working in a school context
with the immediate achieve to like
virtual learning i think
i saw how like the pandemic kind of like
affect the students
um with the struggle with all this like
uncertainty
and how we kind of like think about like
how we could learn design
from home as well because with this like
virtual many thing
and even when there are so many online
resources available i feel that
there's still this lacking of like how
we could provide
multi-disciplinary learning hands-on
learning
and soft skills to connect with like
people and stuff like that so
i i think it was like a struggle for the
student and also for the staff as well
and i
kind of feel less connected to the rest
because
uh i think many of us also feel that way
to like what
our claims are like the people that we
used to work with to collaborate with um
we kind of let us detach from each other
even though we can connect
with each other through online so yeah i
think the economy cannot
even elevate the importance of human
interaction
it does feel like we have a little bit
of screen fatigue setting in
okay for you what's life been like
i think most of it online i would say
and i think it's very much
like related to the previous question
that you asked about how all these
information is so
accessible and i think like having all
these like design information online
i think i still quite enjoy being a
designer
although i also like zero i also make a
lot of stuff like very hands-on
but i think for me what impacted me the
most was more on the environment
like knowing that of course not being
able to be physically
be at the show we lose something like
the tactility and the kind of
interaction
we have with people but we see that
there's a lot of like good
impact for the environment and for our
earth like whether it's like
the air quality or like sustainability
and
i think yeah i think that's the thing
that we lose something we but we also
gain a lot
and i think that's for me the biggest
impact for
yeah so you're referring to the show in
milan that didn't happen just in general
like how all these informations are just
going online and it's much more easy to
access
yeah yeah we we need to find the middle
ground don't we yeah
and kevin for you what's how's your life
and your discipline been affected
by covert so i guess in general it has
been a very
sobering experience for past year
more so when i was because i graduated
this
and i year see there is definitely a
huge difference
in the way that different people would
approach
them so i would say it's suffering
because
we are there are definitely moments
where it's dotted with isolation not
that we
choose to but we are sort of set in the
situation
for the better of ourselves for
community
but i guess the simple lining behind all
this is that you start to see two things
one is that
people are already creative all
designers are very creative
we start to pivot we start to think
about
how else can we reach our needs how else
can we
design around things even if we do not
have the capability
so that's one thing i think the other
one is we start to appreciate what we
have
uh whether it's diverse community
or the resources that we use so i guess
these are the two things that
i'm rather thankful for um one is that
you know i get to appreciate things
better my family matter
and the other one is the fact that it
reminds us of how creative we can be
and how we can think about alternative
methods
okay i'm going to stick with you kevin
and i want to talk about what defines
the before covert and the after covert
state of mind
and how's that how's the pandemic
influenced how you're thinking about
your design practice
so i would say perhaps in a nutshell
what defines pre-covert and post-project
is often
this shift in our needs right there is
i mean if not sure if everyone is
familiar with muscle hierarchy or needs
but essentially what it does or what it
explains is
how our actions are driven by a set of
needs starting with our physiological
needs
so food and shelter and then move up
slightly higher to safety needs and
eventually our identity so
self-actualization
and what defines the preview and the
postcode is how
there are certain emphasis on certain
needs
so i'm sure all of us will realize that
during the
event during this phase 3 right in
singapore
we find that there is a certain emphasis
on safety needs or the need to connect a
sense of connection
so that's that is what sets the
difference
it has more pronounced desire to connect
not just virtually basically so
how that has affected me i would say
generally you know in my practice and
the way i see things i'm always
focused on two things one is behavior
not necessarily just human related
but also the people or the organisms
around us and how the behavior impact
environment
so i would say if anything the pandemic
has
validated or rather sort of show me that
it is important to create
these two things so how people behave as
well as
how people will get in situations
how about for you yun roon yunru the pre
and post
state of mind and how has that affected
your design practices
because we are training to anticipate to
look far
and to anticipate this kind of situation
to feel this
issue and the situation so i feel like
it didn't really affect me
and and if you were to see my project
like i didn't wait for the pandemic to
happen
in order to design this but we focus
more on care
and also like elderly which is like the
issue that we already have like
aging population and stuff so
did it affect your practice cheryl i
think if anything it affirmed
my values the things i'm interested in
for my
in my design practice so actually i i
enjoy working with materials i enjoy
like very tactile experiences
and um during kovi i think before kovy
we were a little bit more like
everyone has a very fast pace of living
we travel from one place to another
without being very
conscious or aware of what we're coming
in contact with
but the circuit breaker being um at home
the whole period for
three plus months i think it made um
i mean we still we are still very
fast-paced and we're saying well i think
it's in our black we can't
we can't get rid of this like
effectiveness efficiency kind of like
mindset
but i think that's an added um level of
uh
mindfulness because i mean partially for
our fear because like
we're more concerned about like the
surfaces that we come in contact with
but at the same time i think because we
spend so much time within the four walls
i'm isolated at home with our families
with the same objects
we um grow to be a bit more
aware of like the the different objects
that we come in contact with
like for example me and myself at home i
mean with my family
i i got to cook a lot more during this
covet period so i developed like this
relationship with
the different kitchen utensils and tools
at home like why i like
certain walks better why i like certain
pens better
because of like how it works if it's
easier to wash and stuff like that
so i think because of that then it made
me appreciate like
like the propensities of different
materials even better yeah
inch one i think
in terms of sustainability it affected
um a bit for me because like for my
project
actually i'm looking into how we don't
want to contribute to like plastics
plastic waste and i think
in the past i tried to look at it at a
very small scale because like
sustainability is such a big word and
you're always a bit afraid to
approach it but then through the cove it
also feels like the
impact just hit so hard and they just
suddenly you just see like mask on the
floor
disposable packaging everywhere because
of food deliveries
even with like all the stop of
production in factories and
it really made me like think twice about
like our buying decisions and
even like our the luxury to travel
and all these things so i think
sustainability has always been something
that think about
but then maybe i need to think bigger
than like what i am at the moment so
in that sense i think it has affected my
thinking
okay i'd like to ask about change
because you know we've
all experienced rapid change over the
last year and
as you've said we we've realized that we
actually can adapt it's not that hard
um but what's the past year revealed to
you about how
change happens does it always have to be
a top-down process
can the public feel empowered and
enabled to make change as well
and what are some of the most
significant changes you've been
observing
kevin well
so we i guess often
change or rather what defines a
successful change
is one where it's often two-pronged
for people so in this case of course
there will be top-down initiatives
naturally policies in place but there
will also be
i believe the grassroots level
initiatives that are
used to accelerate that change or to
bring about
a successful or meaningful outcome so
just to give an example during the
circuit breaker uh the local hawkers had
part time
simply because um some of the partners
may not be on registered platforms
for delivery and hence they do not get
exposure that they require
so of course there are certain reliefs
and certain support that's provided
by government or certain organizations
but it's so heartening to see that there
are local initiatives by
creatives so for example i think local
photographers
is that the hawkers they get their food
sort of that there's
greater exposure for them and therefore
um there's potentially
greater revenue but at the same time
it's also a way for
general's creative to build their
relationship and then your opportunity
so i guess what this highlights is one
is that this pandemic sort of changed
the way that we perceive how things can
be done to businesses
and i think the second one is that it's
it's quite heartening to see how we can
use technology
to pivot businesses and not just
businesses but also the way we think
about
things yeah there's potential for agency
for yourself and to create
it for others as well okay how about you
cheryl
um i think i agree with uh kevin i think
it's both
uh for sure like i mean authority i mean
singaporeans we are quite we're quite
obedient to the authorities for sure
but at the same time i think that uh the
community has a huge part to play
not just designers i mean as designers
we do
i don't know if i can speak for most
designers but my impression is that most
designers
who want to make a change like we're
we're designers because we want to make
a change
and uh i mean aside from that i think uh
there's a lot of community efforts like
maybe it perhaps is ripple effect like
even from like um
like neighbors like putting hand
sanitizers in lift for everyone to share
uh to make a change to make everyone
more aware to like aunties
sharing like different ways of pressing
the lift buttons to like kind of keep
your hands free
uh during the covet period and another
thing that i kind of noticed like kind
of like change
um like change from the community is
that during the
circuit breaker period there was a spike
in numbers of
small business uh entrepreneurs uh
doing like little crafty like like
making things on their own and like uh
doing bakes and stuff i i think in a way
it's it's comfort for themselves by the
same time when they sell these products
when they're soaked to other people it's
comfort for other people as well so i
think
that there are many ways that um
everyone
can make a change yeah so it it's it's
both top-down
and also um as an individual
yeah okay i think i'm going to jump to
your projects and just
um in case people aren't fully familiar
with your work
could you each give us a bit of a
rundown of what your project's about and
what makes it
um particularly relevant to the pandemic
era
should we jump to the back to the
project slides
who'd like to start who have we got
cheryl you're coming first
um my project okay so um for me uh it's
kind of
threading like the in between the role
of uh clothing
uh for like what what is clothing for
could it be for objects and
spaces and furniture as well and
actually i started
um as a i started this project as my
thesis project
uh because i was interested in i came
from a family background where my mom
and my aunt say well
so i was interested in like think
rethinking like how and i have us
so i have a i have this special thing
for clothing already and coming from an
industrial design background uh
i think i i was very interested in like
um figuring out i think it was
was it was a self exploration journey uh
to figure out like um
how can industrial design value add to
like the clothing construction
uh uh industry and also um
so i started like playing with different
materials and i found this very
interesting material that was
used for waterproofing in typically and
i used it
as i was trying out and then i found out
that oh it could it could create this
splitting pattern with this
uh this very normal handheld heat sealer
that i found
uh to to create air pockets and then
through this air pockets
instead of just um like it's kind of a
reverse
reverse process it's uh instead of form
follows
sorry is it sorry form follow function
is it's a function follows
form or maybe like a function follows
material and uh
uh yeah function follows the the idea
the idea of like using this textile and
using air
this resource that's so readily
available around us free of charge
and creating uh meaningful objects with
it
yeah could we jump to yunroo's slits so
for my project
essentially rewind it's a platform that
leverage on familiar gestures
and multi-sensory stimulations from
meaningful recollections for elderly
dementia
i think as the society greatly coped
with
adjusting the new normals um during this
pandemic period we find ourselves at
forgetting the struggles of elderly
especially those
with dementia they are more unbearable
because
they are being confined to stay at home
because most of us
encourage their elderly to stay at home
and i feel the lack of activity is kind
of like
because they are uh their condition
uh rapidly direct even more
and so that let me design
think about like how we could technology
use technology
for once to kind of like connect
the elderly with the family members and
this led me to design like new
activities that
using technology to help elderly during
this period of time
yeah okay uh
okay my my project is a soap machine
called the mass production of happiness
honestly i didn't design this for the
pandemic
but then like when i designed the sew
machine it was just like
purely out of like destinations for like
machines
and um suddenly the pandemic happened
and i got
a little bit relevant
this is the ideal product for the
pandemic from my point of view
not only making soap but making a such a
wonderful experience
as well but then the whole idea behind
it like the bigger idea is actually
still back to sustainability because
like within the cosmetic industries
one of the biggest ways a product is
actually soap bottles and
um the whole project is actually to
envision a future with no more soap
bottles but
just like an additional new retro that
helps with the environment so
like maybe now if we are cleaning
ourselves
we contribute waste and then we are not
cleaning the environment so
with a machine where you clean yourself
you're also indirectly helping to clean
the environment
and yeah besides washing hands i think
yeah that's the bigger idea behind it
yeah and kevin you have three projects
yeah i mean since we're all being honest
the first project which is
definitely not designed for dynamic
right but the theme
right that echo represents is safety and
i believe
safety in the building is often very
relevant
often very important regardless of
whether there's a pandemic or not
so it's actually what echo is is it
stands for
a behavior insight that when here in
singapore
or rather in the uk when i was working
on this project people tend not to
move right they tend to dismiss it
because
and so what i wanted to do was leverage
on
fear which is actually a natural defense
mechanism for people where to get to
safety
and to use fear in a very constructive
way so i sort of
represented fear in the form of tension
that's represented as a balloon
or rather inflatable and what happens is
people have
this irrational fear of balloons
expanding not on the fact that they were
called
but for the fact that they are not sure
when to open
right so that nudge that sort of nudges
people to
move away from danger the second part of
course for apple is that
it also helps to facilitate pathfinding
so it's able
to be deployed as it expands to to sort
of
lock up certain pathways that are
allowed to fire according to each other
the next two projects are more focused
on tai chi particular which is
i guess more highlighted right that was
highlighted
hygiene is very important the first
project is older
odoring right it uses again
our natural response to bed
to keep our hands away and why i decided
to do that well it's quite simple
the thing is that people right in
general we touch our faces
unconsciously whether you believe it or
not over the last hour
about 20-30 times and we do this
has it been any studies do we still do
it as much have we got it in our brains
now
during pandemic not to do that i guess
the
education does help but these these
things are something that expect in
terms of
when naturally cells and i guess what i
would try to do was
to design a content measure
in a way that utilizes another natural
response
to a natural behavior and the last
project
is subtitles right it appeals
generally to children's sense of wonder
and curiosity
because at that age they are very
natural exporters
but because they're explorers their
hands are often dirty
right so the idea of cleaning is very
complicated since we spend most of our
time getting dirty
right and so what happens is we see some
stickers or tattoos
now there are extension stickers we have
a soap room at the top that
adults or the parents can rely on
children
and so the adult can use it as a
training tool but also motivation to
get attributed to what happens and
because their goal is not what happens
but rather to undergrad technology
behind
the surface cell and they can do so
okay thanks everyone you know when i
looked at your projects across a lot of
them
what i was seeing was a real sense of
the intangible
surfacing of things not being entirely
fixed
so you know more emphasis on process
rather than on
you know the fixed final form of things
so for each of you why do you think
that is what does that say about the
kinds of relationships that we want
to have with things these days and what
does it say about the role of the user
of the object
who'd like to field that one first
ingredient
okay i think of
personally i think i appreciate process
more than
results maybe in the nature of like
being uh
someone who's into research i also feel
like that's
um something that i appreciate the most
like the process of researching
and also that um actually in the
in my project itself the whole idea is
the process
so to sorry
can i maybe have the image yeah so
actually the if you look at the machine
right the final product it was never
like the actual final result of the
project but the whole idea is to design
the whole process
where you actually make your own soup
and be wary of like
be aware of the things and ingredients
that you choose for
and then you put it through the machine
for for self-care
so yeah so what happens
is that you have to put all the
ingredients through and then in the
process of like
the mixing of the materials you get this
foam
and what actually completes the product
is actually
the whole interaction with it so what i
imagine is more of um
i think in such a fast-paced like
lifestyle um
what i design for is hopefully like
something to help people slow down a
little bit
even though it's just a very simple
thing that we do every day
so that's your selling point it's no
longer that you've got the
the most amazingly cool orange juicer
[Music]
yeah but also the whole like back to the
question of process like
the whole idea of the mass production of
happiness is actually
inspired by how it's made videos so most
of the times it's also a personal
fascination where i just sit there and
just watch like how soap is produced how
anything is produced while running
through all the machines and
is the satisfaction that you get in this
kind of videos that makes you
addicted to this kind of videos and i
also try to like capture this
because i feel like maybe it's just me
but
a lot of people might also enjoy
watching
like this processes of production yeah
okay yunroo would you like to go next i
think for me if you can
see here it's not really led by
marketing like we don't try to
know anything like for myself like it
all started from the human dimension
and then maybe for sure she started more
from the material and the property of
materials
and see for instance she is more from
the usage front of you
and from the exhibition you can see they
are also like the culture rights back
and also
i feel like we all started we all have
like different entry points
uh usually design process we all
have like uh who are the user
[Music]
defines market yeah so i feel that's the
thing that is different because we all
started from like
entry points that's exactly the
interesting point what defines the
market what do we want from things
yeah cheryl what do you think i think i
share quite a similar point of view with
ancient
but i think the interesting part for me
is where the process
coincides with the outcome so for
instance like for insurance well it's
it's
the process is the outcome uh with um
i mean sorry i lost my train of thought
yeah
yeah um and uh i think yeah um before
maybe
uh sorry i need to refer to
yeah i'm just going to add for the
audience this is the first time all of
these emerging designers have
have spoken on a panel and i think
they're doing an amazing job
so go cheryl you can do it
and um i think that um maybe what we're
looking in
nowadays looking like maybe consumers
the market
is that there's a very strong buy and
throw away culture so
in looking at these processes when
people learn to appreciate these
processes it's something that
uh it's it is a form of connection
between the object and the user itself
and this
is this connection when it's like for
example like uh
i'm i'm into materials right so for
example like sorry yanagi's butterflies
too
like muscle briars tubular chest like
all those classics
uh we look at the we look at the the the
object
we look at the form it's beautiful but
what really connects us ultimately is
uh because we when we learn of the
process like how is
how the material is being manipulated or
how it works behind
that uh there's a there's a there's a
it's like the
venn diagram overlapping kind of thing
and uh that's what
creates this lasting impression that
makes us um want to keep these objects
or use these objects for a longer period
of time and i think
that is uh yeah so that's what what we
are looking at nowadays i feel yeah
people
i'm going to jump i know that the clock
is ticking so i'm going to jump to
a question about specific areas of
design so we were talking earlier about
change of course in society and life
brought about by the pandemic
what do you think still needs to change
and i'm going to ask each of you
to include in your answer some reference
to the context of your own project
so for kevin what change would you still
like to see in terms of how we use our
i would prefer to buildings is sort of
the way
spaces are being used in buildings um
i guess if anything the pandemic
revealed to us that spaces
should not be permanent and the fact can
be very creative with how we design
spaces to accommodate
the situation or to accommodate the
needs of the space
so i believe that it's something that is
becoming more important these days and
i would say what i would like to see is
definitely by the design
of more intangible mediums
or rather it supports the creative usage
of
spaces so for example if you've been to
the hawker center or you've been to
what you see in the auditorium now you
see that a lot of tapes right
that are being used and often these
tapes are thrown away discarded and they
add in this environmental
wastage so i guess that could be
impermanent mediums that potentially
start like after
a certain period of time right so this
of course just
of the problem is the point but i guess
what i'm trying to say
add to is just hold up the spaces but
perhaps
cater to different rituals that you
contact in these spaces
interesting i have to put you in touch
with some architects and interior
designers so yunru
what change would you like to still see
in terms of how we care for others and
how we use
technology i think first is to
give special attention to those who are
less familiar with technology
so that they can leverage online
[Music]
[Music]
because it's like an opportunity for
designers to work closely with people
and i feel as a designer we shouldn't
use like
technology as the core but more of like
harnessing the technology strength
without using the human factor
cheryl for for you what change would you
still like to see in terms of the
interfaces we share with others
for me i think it's this factor of
adaptability
and uh interfaces that share a story of
its own
like i mean not really interfaces just
objects like when we
interact with i see okay when i see
interfaces i don't really
refer to like ui the user interface but
i'm off
physical interface physical interface so
everything that we're in contact with i
consider that as an interface
and i i i would like to have it maybe
like we could look into adaptability and
and uh how meaningful like this
interface like
subconsciously or not yeah in the face
with us yeah
and ying what change would you like to
see still in terms of how we
care for ourselves and our environment
i think little changes will be
also super valuable um
as i mentioned earlier i think like
sustainability and if we talk about an
our environment it's always something
that's such a big topic and you're
afraid to approach it like
even for myself and then i feel like
every little difference that we make
right makes a very big difference
because it always has to be a joint
effort and whether like you consciously
decide to bring your own back to the
supermarket
or bring a box to do a takeaway you're
making a little difference and
i think if we can create like more
motivations for ourselves like for
example if you decide to go natural
maybe you're already helped so it's not
like it doesn't always have to be a very
big action
and yeah i hope that in that way we can
motivate ourselves as well
yeah okay thanks everyone is there any
questions from the audience
would anyone like to ask anything
no too small a group okay
then i'm going to finish up with one
last question
could you all tell me
what do you hope to address through
design as you move forward through your
[Music]
the career culture that we have so
i think this is something that has
brought up has been brought up quite
quite a little
um i think magnitude as well as the
environmental
services and
problems related service concerns so
personally for me i
for example if you look at the masks
that we wear
they interactively contribute to this
mountain of waves that we see
so you see them
i guess this also highlights the fact
that there is a shift
from user-centered design to
environments
not just the sense of sustainability but
also considering
the fact that we are not the only ones
in the environment there are also other
mechanisms are animals like like for
example
these are extremely important because
they are accommodating
for us so i guess there is this
shift and i'm heartened to know that
there
are you seeing that happening in design
education a sense of that shift and
being conscious of that shift away from
just thinking about yourself to thinking
about you in
as part of an say ecosystem
there's a much more emphasis in
institutions not just
singapore but i guess also overseas
where
we are no more just thinking about
ourselves but how collectively if we
don't survive together
then we won't survive okay
what do you as you progress through your
career what do you want to be addressing
like how more people can easily connect
and contribute to
improve the life of others because i
strongly believe that
with society strengthen to collect
collaborative
wellness very much cheryl
for me not really like how's it i'm not
really
uh pushing forth for anything but more
of that i think it's more of a learning
journey for myself
to um because i think for me i'm still
like in this i just graduated like one
year
plus a goal and i'm still trying to
figure out like um
how do i bridge my interest interest in
like clothing and
like my background in industrial design
and i'm
observing like human behavior like the
relationship between human and objects
and i i think in in my career i would
like to like further like explore all
these different
aspects yeah
for me in terms of a career
in terms of design i want to bring
out like the stories of people um to be
honest like when
working on the machine i just would like
to share like a process of my research
is that after talking to a lot of people
i realized that
especially in europe a lot of people are
actually choosing
for soap bars or non-soap bottles
the only reason behind it is because
they don't want to contribute to plastic
waste
and like if i were to do this soap
project on my own i'll never get to this
point but it's all these people that
gives me new perspectives
and through my design i also want to
bring out their perspectives on like
sustainability or whether any topics
that i'm actually working on
and yeah i think it's all these people
that actually helped to finish up on
this project and
on like how i actually formulate the
whole project and
the next time like you guys go to the
supermarket and decide to go for
non-soap bottle then i think like that's
what i want to
like remind people of like you don't
have to but then
maybe even thinking about it is already
like making a difference
yeah so that's what like a little like a
subtle stories of people actually change
also so um what i've heard from you all
is a real focus on
empathy like we said right from the
beginning of this discussion a focus on
the ecosystem not the self a focus on
process and i think these are all
really great things to move forward with
with using design into the future and
they should
bode us well so yeah thank you all for
your
informed perspective and i hope that it
it
is bolstered by events like this and
discussions like this and
and infiltrates more the minds of more
people so
thank you all and to our audience in
person and in video thank you very much
for joining us
please join me in thanking our speakers
and uh so that will conclude the
discussion event um you're welcome to
continue enjoying the exhibition
downstairs while it's still there before
it comes down
um but do remember to keep your mask on
and keep your distance from others
and we wish you all a better 2021 stay
safe and well and thank you and good
night